this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah I'm will today I'll be talking
about trying to understand how
environmental factors influence
contamination of maize by mycotoxins in
a very diverse smallholder farming
system in Tanzania so just some
background about why mycotoxins are risk
these are secondary metabolites produced
by crops fungal pathogens in the
tropical lowlands maize is primarily
affected by two classes of mycotoxins of
athletics ins and commonness ins very
different chemical structures but both
are toxic to both human and animal
health both cause e rots we have
Aspergillus era and Fusarium era
illustrated in extreme cases here and
athlete oxidants are more common
extremely hot temperatures while few
Manas ins slightly more moderate but
there's significant overlap and athlete
oxidants are more toxic with regulatory
limits that are excuse me orders of
magnitude lower than for fume honest n'
so from a landscape wide scale these
toxins are highly influenced by the
environment and a nice study done by
Laura Smith and Samuel motika from our
lab they looked at eastern and western
Kenya where there is sort of more rain
versus semi-arid areas in eastern Kenya
and found that here in the semi-arid
areas there's more aflatoxin while in
the Rainier areas there's less oxygen
and it's not shown here but or if your
Manas in the relationship was reversed
with more few monofin here and less in
eastern Kenya so this kind of gives you
a sense that there are spatial dynamics
that are related to the environment for
the production of each of these toxins
and when we think about what sort of
risk factors environmental risk factors
there are or mycotoxin contamination in
maize you really have to contextualize
it within the maize growing season so
infection of maize ear rots
really
during the reproductive stages spores of
the fungus in fact either via silks or
via some sort of injury to the ear and
so a stressed plant during this stage
will be more susceptible to infection
and subsequent contamination so if a
plant experiences drought during this
time then it is more likely to have
mycotoxin at harvest whereas later in
the season after fungal establishment on
the ear rains at maturity are actually
more likely to make a more conducive
environment for fungal growth and result
in more contamination across the season
soil health is very important as it's
low poor soil health such as low
nitrogen low carbon contributes to plant
stress and makes a plant more
susceptible to infection so I'm
interested in how all of these
environmental factors could use to model
micro toxin contamination across region
and so the study site is Congo District
here in central Tanzania and Congo
district is a semi-arid smallholder
farming system we have collaborators
working on a child with a nutrition
trial there and as part of that work
we've established this contamination by
both aflatoxin and fume honest in' and
so I'm just showing here
that's childhood stunting which is what
this trial is looking at is elevated in
Congo and across all of Tanzania so this
is especially relevant in these areas as
even earlier this year a high aflatoxin
contamination of maize has been reported
to cause an outbreak of athletic
psychosis which resulted in eight deaths
in regions bordering Kawa so to try and
get at this question of how the
environments influencing the geographic
dispersion of micro toxins across
smallholder farming system I first went
to Kong WA interviewed farmers and
sampled basic grain mills then
quantified
Mays and aflatoxin values by
enzyme-linked immunosorbent assay next
acquired remote sensing imagery of
different environmental risk factors and
finally tried to model mycotoxins a
function of these remote sensing
indicators so concentration of
mycotoxins as a function of things like
NDVI soil carbon harvest etc so for my
survey I visited Congo district and over
the course of 17 days visited 888 grain
mills and interviewed 306 customers of
these grain mills and took a sample of
maize from each one these grain mills
are sort of local nodes of maize
processing so everyone within a maybe 5
kilometer radius of that grain mill goes
there to have their flour or their whole
maize ground into flour for household
use so it allows you to understand local
variants in mycotoxins as well as sort
of geo reference that so you can look at
environmental indicators so from a
questionnaire here's my research
assistant john Shanga talking to a
customer outside of a grain mill we
learned many things but just a few
highlights was that planting date was
generally december-january harvests were
mostly in May I was there late May early
June and people would sort of harvest
portions of their field at a time so it
wasn't a single date for all of the
harvest and all but one respondents said
that they experienced drought this year
and when they experienced drought was
mostly in the middle or middle end of
the growing season which correlates to
those risk factors that other papers
have stablished and when I did my Eliza
assays and looked at mycotoxin
contamination within my samples here is
log transformed aflatoxin this fold red
line is the legal limit of ten parts per
billion and you can see that a vast
majority of samples exceed the legal
limit and many of them by orders of
magnitude
dude over the legal limit just showing
how extreme the contamination by alpha
toxins or the season a few monofin
contamination relative to the legal
limit was not quite as severe so in
terms of looking at growing season
indicators of crop health
I used normalized difference vegetation
index from a modus aqua satellite and
hopefully what you can get from this
this gif is that across a growing
growing season there's both temporal and
spatial variation in NDVI values and I
should mention that each sample had a
NDVI averaged over sort of the distance
someone walked to the grain mill so I
knew their farm was X kilometers away
but I had no in which direction so it's
for someone two kilometres away it would
be a relatively smaller radius versus
eight kilometers would be a larger
radius of average values and you can
also use NDVI to compare to previous
years with this data set and so here at
a hundred percent is the median NDVI of
approximately twenty years of data and
you can see that for the beginning of
the growing season things were more or
less at the median then after that
drought began in the middle of the
season you can see that compared to past
years and dbi plummeted where and then
rains started again late in the season
and you see a sort of rebound effect and
I want to show sort of how this
correlates to our thoughts of drought
affecting during the reproductive growth
period and then rains occurring again at
the end of the growing season I also
looked at
soil health using the soil grids 250
meter data set this has many soil
attributes at high spatial resolution
and in particularly looked at organic
carbon stock which is the amount of
carbon within a given area and see some
greener areas these are like mountains
where there's actually no farming and
there's more trees but across mostly
these white and beige areas that are
very low values are where most of the
farming is going on and so that sort of
is how I'm trying to monitor this other
risk factor of soil health so I use
several different models to try and
model both alpha toxins and human
essence only models for athletics in
were significant based on environmental
factors I ended up choosing a mixed
effects model incorporating both fixed
and random effects a reduced model found
that the fixed effects of NDVI in
april/may and organic carbon stock from
the 15 to 30 centimeter root zone along
with the random effects of each grain
mill so samples were associated with the
grain mill and I used that as my random
effects in doing this I want to focus
first on the estimates for my fixed
effects so in April so nearing the end
of the grain the growing season there's
a negative association between aflatoxin
and nvv I sort of as we'd expect the
more stress crops were had were
negatively associated with alpha toxin
whereas in May after the growing season
there was a positive association shown
here sort of maybe suggesting that areas
that had more rain at the end of the
growing season were more likely to be
contaminated and as other studies have
shown organic carbon was negatively
associated with alpha toxin so in total
the fixed effects explained 11.2% of the
variance in athlete's oxen which is not
a huge number but for such a small area
and a diverse system it is significant
and when I account for my random of
along with fixed effects and conditional
r-squared it's almost 28% I wanted to
see how well this worked for predicting
if I held samples out of my training set
so doing that I could compare predicted
and observed aflatoxins in my test set
and found a strong correlation between
predicted and observed though I should
note that there because of the low
variance explained it's a pretty narrow
range of predicted values so takeaways
from this are that Congo District in
2019 had an extremely tough maize
growing season that resulted in
significant aflatoxin contamination
however it did provide an opportunity to
really understand how these
environmental risk factors that are
freely available and our pre harvest
could be used to create predictive
models obviously such models would need
further validation across locations and
years but could help plant breeders
understand variance in mycotoxin hammock
contamination across regions or even
public health experts who want early
warning systems for these types of
problems with that I really want to
thank many people including everyone in
the Nelson lab our collaborators with
the mycotoxin mitigation trial I
mentioned John I'm stronger my research
assistant all the participants and
people in Congo who made this much
easier than it could have been and
funding from the Atkinson Center and the
an Audi Center so thank you and I we
have time for a few questions for will
yeah yeah yeah you're very correct so he
asked about the difference between pre
harvest and post-harvest contamination
aflatoxins are notorious for
especially post-harvest problems and
there's a lot of research on storage
techniques and processing techniques to
reduce that I wanted to just focus on
the pre-harvest aspect and so actually
that's why I was when I visited it was
directly after harvest so samples for
only days or weeks from being in the
field so I want to sort of isolate that
part and then understanding post harvest
issues it's a whole nother part of it
but yeah yeah so I I did end my
questionnaire have questions about what
seats people were growing and all those
kinds of things and it is there's first
very low understanding of what I mean
people are growing open pollinated saved
seeds this is I think I met one person
out of over 300 who had purchased hybrid
seed or something like that so there are
no inputs so very diverse very diverse
genetics and so that was something I was
interested in trying to parse out but
was ultimately kind of impossible yeah
but genetics are highly quantitative low
heritability for this but interested in
trying to look at that a little more to
one said they did not so 305 out of 306
so that was like a very unanimous like
loud signal to me that it was a big
problem yeah mark in terms of cultural
practices a lot of it has to do with I
mean some say early maturity early
maturity variety
so they get out of the field field
quicker proper drying techniques their
proper storage techniques so even some
trying to use anoxic storage conditions
dry storage conditions this is really
like an issue that has involves so many
so many different factors even sorting
post-harvest but you know in these very
very low input systems it's difficult to
say there's exactly one thing that can
solve it all yeah all right let's think
will this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu